[Applause]
this is the end of democracy
this is in the end but this is how it
starts like
i think like i like this one
catastrophic thinking because you've
experienced
because i see it yeah and i know how it
starts it starts real kind of like
innocent [ __ ] like hey wouldn't it be
nice if we had like more of this
and then you look up and that everything
is everything is is crazy so you're
right people overreact but also
sometimes you got to overreact to get
people to take this [ __ ] seriously
yes right yes because i've been
concerned about america
long term my only concern with america
is it being like torn in half
that's a big concern yeah like that's i
think that's like the biggest intention
no no no no no you're right
you're right you're right no no meaning
like um
uh and that is my biggest objection to
trump right
and i think that like anybody's
listening to the podcast like i've been
incredibly fair to [ __ ] trump
right like but i think they're so fair
like you know what i'm saying but like
you know they're like
so fair but it's like there is there is
something that you have to
you have to recognize that when you
don't try
at all to reach across the aisle right
now some people are like super pro trump
might go
but what about prison reform or
something like that okay and that's fair
that is that is but i don't know i don't
think that like
prison reform is a strictly democratic
position
right i think you could even argue that
conservatives are like yo we don't want
all these taxes going towards prisons
like get that [ __ ] out
whatever it doesn't matter point is when
you only try to satisfy your base and
you're not reaching across the aisle at
all
you create a you create a line of
division
that is incredibly thick and by
emboldening your base
you infuriate the opposition to the
point
where they hate each other and when you
hate the other person when they're
literally evil to you
that is the end of democracy because now
we can't have the conversation if you
think i'm evil
right and i think you're evil how are we
supposed to meet in the middle about
this abortion [ __ ] and to that point i
think a lot of
trump's appeal at least early on to
republicans is look how much liberals
hate him
look how crazy he drives them i love how
crazy he drives my enemy
enemy of my enemy that's my friend yes
i'm not saying that's the only reason
there's a
whole [ __ ] version of reasons he got
elected that's one of them i think
and i and i think it just sucks that you
have biden who's such a [ __ ]
stiff right who is the only other actual
corpse yeah who's just a corpse
and now you're in this really shitty
situation right because
you recognize the division right like
that's what i was really annoyed with
aoc posted right he's like i don't care
if you don't like what he has to say
vote for him anyway it's like what well
i think i think
what that's the end of democracy right
there she's addressing
she's addressing people who clearly
aren't gonna vote for trump but then
think that like the answer is to just
not vote
like if your thing is that trump is evil
and trump is bad and he's ruined the
country
and so what are you gonna do about it
i'm gonna stay my ass home on election
day it's like
buddy that ain't gonna solve the
situation right now
she's doing exactly what you're talking
about trump did which is i'm appealing
to the base exactly she's not reaching
across for
any like person who's like i might be
voting for trump but now she makes a
great
point i'll vote for biden right that's
not who she's talking to she's talking
to the people
who are either going to vote for biden
or not vote at all and and i think that
that's what annoyed me about it because
i hate that kind of tribalism right
like what i want more than anything in
america right now like literally if i
could pick a candidate it would be the
candidate that doesn't tear the [ __ ] in
[ __ ] half
and i don't know if biden is capable to
mend anything together
can't even put a [ __ ] sentence
together and i don't know how he's going
to put this country back together
at the same time i am concerned that
like trump
as we get close to the election is going
to lean further into the base
because that is what he does
and it's brilliant what he did we can't
act like he's struggling because it
works
no no it works but my point is this is
like
once he once you've introduced the game
this is a new game now the new game
is i lean into my base yep then
the aim of the game is to win you're not
going to win the election like
i know he's playing by these rules i'm
gonna play i'm playing ones and two or
by ones only he's playing ones and two
see i see this is where i i disagree
with you a little bit
i think the democrats underestimate what
their base is
and i think that republicans
underestimate what their base is as well
so like trump is leaning into the
extremes right right and because of that
democrats have leaned into their
extremes right and they've really
created this polarization
where there's this entire gap in the
middle of the country which
most of us probably finn i can't speak
for you but i know most of us in this
room right now
are sitting here in the middle going
these people on the left are [ __ ]
ludicrous
these people on the right are [ __ ]
ludicrous can we just
figure out how to just kind of respect
each other i don't want you to get
killed by the cops
i don't want to pay a lot in taxes let's
figure i don't want to go to war abroad
for no [ __ ] reason
and also [ __ ] chyna like i think we can
all agree on all those things
i think we can come together but because
they're doing so much bickering and
there's so much polarization
this gap is open in the middle and
they're too much of a [ __ ] both sides
are too [ __ ] just hop in the middle
and biden was supposed to be the one in
the middle but he can't put a [ __ ]
sentence together here's the thing
remember how they said
the rockets and lakers this is a
series for the future of the nba yeah
because if the rockets won
then everyone says [ __ ] centers we don't
need it
we don't need any of that [ __ ] it was
important for some people that the
lakers win
just so that we don't lose our [ __ ]
minds yeah the rockets
are like trump except trump won
so what you're describing while yes i
love centers and i love power forwards
and i love the game being like some post
ups and some three-pointers and a mix of
everything
that's what you're describing but the
[ __ ] four years ago when shot
only threes didn't have a center
and one and that's why everyone's
playing the game now there's no
i understand you gotta win andrew and i
you're right maybe there is something in
the middle there that could appeal or
whatever
but the idea is that the team that won
is the one that dictates how we're gonna
play the next rules this is my
my only pushback that would be that i
think you can apply those same rules
to the middle which is this massive base
that is existing and thirsty
and dying for someone to speak for them
but they're not playing it
they're just not [ __ ] planned there's
this literally 90
of the country is up for grabs and are
being forced to make this decision that
actually doesn't satisfy their palette
because that's the only thing that's out
there and i think it's a gross
miscalculation by both
sides you know what it's like to your
point you only get a video with a
million views or whatever on youtube
yeah and then you have 10 000 comments
and everybody's arguing
yeah 990 000 people didn't care enough
to comment
you you see ten thousand people arguing
though and you're like oh my god look at
the [ __ ] everybody's so angry
most people don't give a [ __ ] now what i
was also thinking is one silver lining
that could come from this divide
is two more parties coming to the middle
and now we have four parties
nothing would be better to me that would
be in four parties extreme extreme
middle left middle that would be dope
i'm all for more parties that's the one
thing i would say about a lot of
european countries that are
they have better than us not all of them
because some of them are just like us or
it's basically two parties yeah but the
idea of having like
multiple parties that [ __ ] is cool man
it's nice to have options it's always
nice to have options
question so you said you hate um the way
aoc is leaning that she's like
just appeasing or trying to talk to her
base tribalism
tactic that trump is doing correct like
i'm critical of both of them for doing
the same thing yes but what's a lesser
to evil re-electing trump
who's continuing to divide up the
country or electing biden who yes he has
a little trouble putting sentences
together but he has people around him
that can at least
help him manage it and he's better at
trying to keep the country through
let me let me just uh let me just poke
holes in that logic because i think that
is solid logic and i think a lot of
people take that
right and they go down that route
they're like well at least with this guy
he's got good people around him
right which is fair but i don't know
who's around him and me as a voter
and let's not talk about me andrew
schultz like me just john doe regular
voter guy who's like
yeah okay fine i know the guy's a corpse
but maybe he's got really smart people
around him and i can vote for the smart
people
i don't know kamala's practices i don't
know kamala's
strategies i've got great tasting tims
but you know i'm saying like the average
person doesn't know so you're not really
giving me anything to latch on to
and you know aoc is coming out here and
she's like
this is a vote for marginalized people
it's like cut it out dude like you have
kamala
and joe biden who do not have the best
records when it comes to marginalized
people
so cut out the [ __ ] you're basically
just going hey
don't vote for the other guy which
didn't work four years ago when they ran
on don't work for the other guy
it's like how long do we have to prop up
the democrats until they actually
take us seriously and the same goes for
republicans until they take us seriously
and give us someone that actually
appeals to our base i'm i'm without what
i'll say which is
the idea is that if you vote for this
guy we're gonna play dirty now but once
he gets in there
you're gonna start to fix this [ __ ] and
make it look like a regular country
again where
you reach across the aisle you do all
that other [ __ ] and you know and kind of
try and
lead from the middle but for now yeah
everyone's gonna have to get the guns
out and get and get dirty with it i
guarantee you and i mean this a
thousand percent if there was
a centrist candidate
i mean it's a thousand percent who was
wasn't even attached to a party who
literally ran as an independent
but was smart enough to make the logical
arguments that the american people
need to be made cuban mark
[ __ ] cuban if mark cuban
[ __ ] it if mark cuban came out like
literally it would have to be someone
smart enough and successful enough to
fund their campaign but if they came out
and just made these logical [ __ ]
arguments that americans want to hear
and they weren't worried about the
pushback
he is pro-black lives matter anti-tax
he's the guy hey listen what's happening
black people's terrible
also i don't want to pay taxes
pretty simple sexually harasses women
both sides can support that so we're
three for three on the couch
you